Obama administration is putting a has
put in charge of a director that is an
architecture I guess formerly an
architect and this is a good idea to put
architects in politics I think so I
think they're certainly trained to be
Jack's of all trades that can handle
multiple problems mulk multitask and and
think in many scales I'm not really
familiar directly with this individual
personally that Obama's put in charge
for HUD I think that are you know if you
look at our past administrations
successes or i should say failures it's
been it's been pretty miserable i mean
the the issue in new orleans and how in
I don't know how many years it's been
that we've failed to make some kind of
contribution to the people in New
Orleans kind of return them to a state
of of conviviality and and lifestyle
that they were used to or even just how
is these folks is is appalling I think
putting an architect in charge of the
problems is especially one with urban
design skills would would be almost a
fantasy and I'm glad the Obama
administration is is looking towards
some architects to think about this I
wish we can make it happen even faster
i'm surprised that something like the
beijing olympics seemingly happened
overnight just a few years they went
from zero to a thousand and impressed
the world with a grand munificent
display of architecture and and culture
and yet America can't really solve its
its housing crises so architects have
been and that's all across the globe
have been working on this problem for a
good century and I don't think we still
have the right answer but to keep us off
the front lines like many past
administrations I think was the wrong
answer
if I was just see Barack in an elevator
some place in DC I think that the advice
I would give him is to put more folks
like architects in charge of some major
problems that are out there I think that
we can actually reify them visually show
what those solutions might be in many
different camps I certainly wouldn't put
us in charge of the military but I think
we can help retool Detroit a lot better
than the folks there and I think that
we're were fitted to accept that there
was a talk before the you know before
this happened between the McCain camp
and the obama camp about what they
should be promoting in their in their
elections and there I guess the big
issue was Detroit and thinking about
what we can do to save Detroit and I had
two separate answers for that I think
for the McCain camp it would be the
military can save Detroit and there's
some serious reasons why and for the
obama camp there's going to be you know
science and innovation maybe and put
some big thinkers in architecture
involved in retooling Detroit but for
the McCain camp if you think about it
getting to an all electric
infrastructure an all-electric mobile
infrastructure would take something like
the military to do it because DARPA and
those folks in the military could make a
decision like that and that decision
would be let's make tanks run on
electric drives let's make jeeps run
electric drives and let's do that
because those engines have almost no
moving parts so they're very easy to fix
they make no sound and I think military
folks like stealth it's a pretty good
thing they're a switchable fabric in
other words the component can be taken
out of the tank and put into the Jeep
very easily come out of the Jeep and put
it into a helicopter and they're hard to
knock out batteries could be laced
inside all of these vehicles helicopters
jeeps tanks so that if you hit a certain
part of that tank and knock out a
section of the battery power all the
power isn't destroyed it's distributed
throughout the vehicle so it actually
makes a more robust
tank plus with electric systems it goes
from 0 to 100 instantly there's no
throttling that you would find in
gasoline-powered systems or
diesel-powered systems so there's a lot
of reasons to use electric drivetrains
in all of our military vehicles and I
it's the biggest one is because we want
to wean ourselves off of oil we probably
can source that electricity through a
heavy amount of investment in renewables
then we'd have a military that's
completely independent incredibly
powerful and once the military can do
that it certainly can show Detroit of
the trail can give them the direction